[Musique]
je vous souhaite la bienvenue dans notre
émission de la politique et des idées la
politique au sens large ne l'ont entendu
en tout cas les idéaux sens encore plus
large face à la première c'est
maintenant sur martinique la première
radio
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
deux personnalités pour évoquer le 170e
anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé dans les colonies des
processions française et plus
précisément nous allons parler d'autres
conditions des circonstances dans
lesquelles a été signé ce fameux décret
le 27 avril 1848 signé au siège du
ministère de la marine et des colonies
alors dirigée par françois arago qui
avait à ses côtés un sous-secrétaire
d'état aux colonies victor schoelcher
mme ce décret rendant officielle et
définitive
l'interdiction du travail servile en
martinique en guadeloupe en guyane à la
réunion dont le contrat en français de
saint louis du sénégal ainsi que dans
les possessions de commander dépendance
à savoir madagascar et en particulier
nocibé et cette fable pour en parler je
reçois louis-abel bonjour monsieur abel
bonjour monsieur partie vous êtes
historien et spécialiste de l'importance
des libres de couleur ou pour parler le
langage d'aujourd'hui d'aimer l'autre
pas que des mulâtres puisque
effectivement il y avait des noirs en
libre ou si à l'époque avant l'évolution
d'esclaves noirs qui avaient été
affranchis ou qui étaient descendants
deux individus qui étaient libres de
naissance voilà donc votre période de
recherche de spécialité en tout cas
c'est une disons en gros les décennies
avant et un peu après l'abolition de
l'esclavagé donc la première moitié du
19e siècle pour aller pour aller vite
oui pour aller vite même si
effectivement on n'est pas en ga j'ai
abordé le les livres de couleurs depuis
le 17e siècle et ce jusqu'au début du
19e siècle
voilà donc vous avez déjà publié
plusieurs livres sur cette question vous
en étant vous êtes en préparation d'un
troisième si je ne m'abuse d'après ce
qu'il m'a été rapporté oui mais en fait
le prochain livre portera sur une autre
thématique qui concernera les livres
justement ce que dit ce colisée
les individus à l'époque entre le fin
xviiie et l'abolition de l'esclavagé en
1848 question alors en parlant d'alim
j'attends un écrivain également
journaliste
rodolphe etienne qui vient de publier
une traduction entre également cynique
et du décret du 27 avril 1848 il prendra
les missions en cours de route puisque
n'est pas encore arrivé avec cette
question que je me posais qu'est ce qui
lui est arrivé qu'est ce qui est passé
par intel pour voulant traduit en créole
un texte qui peut parler trop ardue
parce que c'est un mélange de
considérations d'ordre politique
philosophique avec un langage du
français du 19e siècle où comment et
pourquoi
comme s'il était depuis et pour quelles
raisons mais tout d'abord celui abel ce
vendredi 27 avril il ya eu jour pour
jour après le cent soixante dix ans
après la signature de ce décret une
cérémonie au panthéon à paris présidée
par le chef de l'état qui a voulu rendre
hommage à certains noms de personnalités
qui ont lutté pour l'émancipation des
esclaves ou plus largement ensuite pour
l'émancipation de la loire en tout cas
des colonisés des cabinets dans que les
anciennes colonies aujourd'hui
l'outre-mer français et donc il s'est
arrêté ainsi sur les tombeaux ou les
plaques commémoratives de condensé de
l'abbé grégoire de victor schoelcher de
félix éboué de toussaint louverture de
louis delgrès sait il y a eu un hommage
également gaston monnerville par
l'intermédiaire d'une comédienne qui
disait un extrait de son texte et à aimé
césaire un comédien jacques martial qui
a lu un extrait de cahiers de retour au
pays natal cérémonie comment dirais-je
étonnante surprenante
non on tire rien n'est pas surprenante
puisque le 27 avril et est inscrit dans
l'histoire nationale comme étant
effectivement le moment où le
gouvernement provisoire à andy fils yale
justement l'abolition de l'esclavagé
aux colonies donc il était normal en
quelque sorte de revenir sur cette date
qui avait mis en avant effectivement les
membres du gouvernement provisoire mais
aussi victor schoelcher par son travail
en amont pour l'abolition de l'esclavagé
aussi en tant que sous secrétaire d'état
aux colonies et comme président de la
commission d'abolition de l'esclavagé
qu'il a présidée et qui va mettre en
oeuvre justement cette abolition est
l'objet de décrets annexe et organique
voilà donc nous allons accompagneront
tout à l'heure si haut c'est d'écrire
parce qu'il n'ya pas un seul des freins
évidemment le décret du 27 avril dont on
parle tant comporte neuf articles bon
qui seront publiés bientôt sur le site
internet de martinique point d'un 1er
mai pour venir à cette semaine 7 avril
elle en effet ce n'est pas étonnant que
le président de la république industrie
particulier puisqu'en fait pendant très
longtemps les populations des anciennes
colonies est devenu autre mère
s'arrêtait le 27 avril sur cette date
oui normalement effectivement avant
qu'on me met en avant le 22 mai en
martinique et les autres dates dans les
autres départements français on
d'outre-mer ont effectivement le 27
avril avait toujours été la dette
officielle préconise et qui était mise
en avant pour cette abolition de
l'esclavagé ni du point de vue national
alors est ce que c'est vrai qu'à marquer
qu'on a un peu oublié puisque jusqu'à et
environ quarante ans une grosse
quarantaine d'années ce 27 avril et s
est débrouillé comme tel même s'il n'y
avait pas le faste que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui même s'il n'avait pas la
dimension militante si je puis dire
et donc est ce que du fait que le
président de la république n'ont pas
créé une tradition puisque ces missives
c'est vrai c'est nouveau c'est la
première fois que le chef de l'état
organisé une cérémonie de cette
importance avec cette sonorité est ce
que ça ne risque pas de créer une
confusion pour chez seat un entrepôt
civile à une multiplication des date de
commémoration de l'abolition du servage
prononcée qu'en histoire les dettes sont
sont là pour rappeler justement les
événements les faits qui se sont passés
déroulé et donc il faut chaque à chaque
fois remettre chaque colis chaque
chacune des dettes à leur place et
effectivement si elle est au niveau du
territoire métropolitain dans la logique
justement après la mise en place de la
deuxième république
là la mise en place d'un gouvernement
provisoire auprès du la reconnaissance
d'un principe de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé qui a été il y traite au
début mars il fallait effectivement
ensuite mettre en oeuvre cette abolition
est dans les faits dans les actes et
rédige effectivement par le biais d'une
commission ce différend décret qui
devait être appliqué ensuite aux
colonies donc la logique nationale et
est mise en avant avec ce niveau là donc
en quelque sorte c'est un geste du
président de la république aujourd'hui
en 2018 signant le fait que
l'étain et à travers lui la république
on reconnaisse toute l'importance de ce
décret et à travers ce décret
l'importance de la décision hautement
politique de libérer les esclaves
il s'agit sans doute de mettre en avant
à nouveau effectivement le rôle qu'a
joué a effectivement ce niveau la
deuxième république et son gouvernement
provisoire et effectivement on verra
ensuite pour convenir martin
principalement une autre partition va se
jouer dans la tente justement de cette
annonce qu'on nous promet depuis
quelques mois aux colonies de voir
justement abolir l'esclavagé
effectivement ce qui se passe au niveau
national aura aussi des répercussions
aux colonies et donc on verra que cette
cette annonce qui tarde à se mettre en
oeuvre aura une des conséquences
beaucoup plus rapide au niveau de la
martinique et qui va qui va aboutir
naturellement à 7 c soulèvement des
esclaves au prix cher et à saint pierre
alors avant de revenir dans le détail si
je puis dire si la mise en oeuvre de ce
décret dans les colonies en particulier
dans celle de la martinique
certains prétendent que en fait tout
était déjà dit tout était déjà
verrouillé c'est expédié en bon employé
comme l'iran d'aujourd'hui le 4 mars le
4 mars un jour de la nomination de
victor schoelcher comme sous-secrétaire
d'état aux colonies
vous pourrez du ministre et de la marine
françois arago et schoelcher qui
instaure des 80 ans une commission
chargée de préparer dans les plus brefs
délais selon les termes du décret du 4
mars
l'émancipation des esclaves dans les
colonisés procession est donc finalement
le cadre avait déjà été fixé à ce
moment-là lesquels peut-être été fixée
effectivement dans les bureaux
du ministère des colonies mais celle
cher en tant qu'artisans de cette
abolition jouer son rôle aussi donc il a
mis en avant ses idées qui n'ont pas
toutes été respectées ni suivi par la
commission puisque la commission
composée de sept membres avec des
individus d'opinion déchéance de
tendances différentes beaucoup plus
modérée que celle cher en général ont
tempéré l'ardeur de l'abolitionniste
qu'il fut alors qu'elle quels ont été
les faits parmi les idées qui n'ont pas
été suivies les idées de chez le chat
qui n'ont pas été suivies deux idées
importantes déjà donné des terres aux
esclaves elle n'a pas été suivie
les indemnisations n'a pas été suivi
donc en disant gratuite je pense que les
ce sera l'un des problèmes récurrents
dans l'application de l'abolition en
martinique notamment ont fait que les
esclaves étaient attachés à leur casier
alors jardin donc et ils n'ont obtenu ni
l'un ni l'autre et donc ils ont voulu
ils ne mettront beaucoup de difficultés
à se séparer de leurs cadets du jardin
en sachant qu'ils n'ont pas été
indemnisées pour justement parler de
l'abolition du servage
alors il y a des idées de chèques n'ont
pas été super mais il est vrai aussi que
la commission
les v a auditionné un certain nombre de
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes ce soir
que ce soit des militants
abolitionnistes français bon teint ou
natifs des colonies comme par exemple
victor masi lim qui sera député plus
tard mais il ya également des planteurs
ou de leur déléguer leurs représentants
à paris qui ont été auditionnées et
apparemment à cette commission si on
retrouve est ballotté entre plusieurs
logiques différentes plusieurs
contradictions tout à fait chaque route
en voulant fait entendre sa voix donc
les planteurs les propriétaires des
habitations
naturellement ne voulait pas être lésé
par cette abolition de l'esclavagé qui
d'une manière générale qu'il ne
revendiquait pas et donc il fallait
aussi prendre en compte naturellement la
masse de la population qui allait être
affranchi par le décret dont les
représentants ont certaines zones de
couleurs déjà libre vrai depuis un petit
moment notamment celui qui a été oublié
par la commission d'abris son esclave à
cyril 17
alors justement sans revenir sur
l'inimitié on n'a pas dit aux puces
entre cyrille bissette l'abolitionniste
martin que par excellence et victor
schoelcher l'un des plus ardents
abolitionniste français c'est vrai que
il étonnant que bissett n'est pas été
intégrés à cette commission alors qu'il
a commencé à militer pour l'abolition
avant même que celle cher là s'engage de
son combat bon non seulement en raison
de leur origine différente et puis de
leur âge également donc si tu avais une
antériorité 2007 sur le front
abolitionnistes et pourtant chez le
chien là les 40 et malgré une pétition
des amis de 17 pour le faire intégrer
cette commission
tout à fait cette inimitié remonte
effectivement à la fin des années du
monde au cours de la décennie 230
enfin dernier 630 débutant à 1140 et est
donc bis est effectivement revendre et
revendique qui très tôt au co de vos
débuts de la monarchie de juillet
l'abolition immédiate de l esclavage
notamment par le biais de la revue des
colonies qu'il avait fondé avec d'autres
hommes de couleur est aussi d un avocat
gâtine qui était présent et où le matin
en mettant les miens justement
l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans les
colonies anglaises et ce qu'il fallait
éviter notamment l'édition écueil qu'il
fallait éviter quand serait prononcé la
bri en esclavage au niveau français donc
c'est vrai que depuis dix ans 34 235
qu'on voit que bissett s'engage en
faveur de l'abolition immédiate de l
esclavage chez les chiens ne le fera que
vers 1830 1840 et donc de quelques
années il le précède à ce niveau là mais
surtout qu'il lit on à l'avant-garde du
coup en mouvement abolitionniste
français à ce moment et il n'aurait
d'ailleurs il sera mis de côté
effectivement parce que dans leurs
écrits schoelcher et lui avait les
différents des différences de vue sur
notamment des phrases que les chercheurs
avaient prononcé sur la nature des
relations entre mulâtresse et blanc et
donc il avait mis en exergue justement
ces femmes et avait parfois une petite
vertu
pour résumer et donc d'où la naissance
synthèse des mulâtres de manière géniale
voilà ce qui avec ses 17 ce qui avec ses
17 et il a tenu à justifier est rectifié
pour lui ce qu'il semblait être qu'une
erreur de jugement de la part de victor
schoelcher alors on parle beaucoup de
chercheurs encore aujourd'hui comme un
artisan majeur de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé dessous ce moment mais en
réalité c'est un vaste mouvement le
mouvement abolitionniste qui comprend
des personnalités d'origine diverses
avec des idéologies différentes y avait
des républicains des libéraux il y avait
ceux qui voulaient abolir l'esclavagé
pour des raisons philosophiques ou
philanthropique dix ans au women
humanitaire dih il y en a aujourd'hui
d'autres qui faisait un simple calcul
économique en démontrant que le travail
servile coûter plus cher on trouve a été
moins rentable que le travail salarié et
n'avait d'autre qui voulaient simplement
que la france enfin simplement la france
s'est modernisé modernisa enfin sur le
plan politique ne cessa d'exploiter des
sommes pratiquement dans ces colonies
donc plusieurs intérêts différents mais
ce move abolitionniste ancien qui date
de la révolution de 1789 inspiré ou
influencer au début par le mouvement
abolitionniste britannique est
extrêmement divers et chercheurs n est
un élément certes majeur mais un élément
parmi d'autres de ce vaste courant oui
un courant nous découvrons puisque
effectivement le coin le coin
abolitionniste anglais a précédé de
quelques années celui français avec la
mise en place d'un société des amis des
noirs 17 48
effectivement il un souvent influencé ce
courant abolitionniste français même
quand il sera mise en sommeil
effectivement à l'époque de napoléon 1er
en dans l'empiré où il orne et racontera
aux reprendra de la vigueur à partir de
la restauration par le biais de la
société de l'amour soutien morale
chrétienne qui sera fondée en dix ans 22
pour justement lutter contre la traite
des esclaves dans l'atlantique mais
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment sous la
monarchie de juillet que le mouvement
abolitionniste français
ayant planché par différents individus
notamment au sein de la société
française pour l'abolition de
l'esclavagé créé en 1834 où nombre de
ministres
la monarchie de juillet feront partie de
cette société
naturellement les libéraux comme on
disait les libéraux est plutôt des
modérés les gens qui sont favorables à
une abolition graduée de l'esclavagé et
qu'il allait avec et qui laisse un
centre suffisamment lointain cette
abolition fige qu'elle soit finalisée
non dans le temps alors juste nous y
reviendrons tout de suite pour vous
préciser on peut aussi à ceux qui l'ont
oublié qu'ils ne savent pas ce qu'est la
monarchie de juillet c'est sûr victime
le conditionnel
comment est elle est commandée cette
vidéo comment disparités alors là cette
monarchie de juillet comme son nom
l'indiqué tire son nom des événements de
la fin du mois de juillet 1830 donc à 27
28 29 les trois jours où le peuple
parisien s'est soulevée contre charles
10 et ses quatre ordonnances qui est
avait pour but de mettre à mal un petit
peu je dirais est à la fois l'origine
législatif et qu'ils disent est eux qui
de l'est aussi dissoudre l'assemblée
à l'époque et la vie s'éteint le roi de
france mais cela étant le dernier mois
en l'occurrence oms à ce moment là le
dernier représentant des bourbons et
donc effectivement un mouvement donc
cette révolution de la rue parisienne
mettra en avant selon l'individu
notamment des républicains qui voudront
donc pour certains d'entre eux aient
entendu renverser le monarque
quand d'autres plus beaucoup plus
modérée voudront simplement changé la
personnalité au sommet de l'état
français et d'où le fait que ce soit un
cousin à charolles a dit ce qui fut
choisi en la personne de louis philippe
fils de philippe égalité duc d'orléans
qui est la branche de la famille royale
la famille lauréates qui succèdent à la
famille bonbons qui début août
digi 130 sera désigné ou comme moi des
français dans un petit groupe
d'individus qui le portera haut au
pouvoir et qui est v sera ainsi puisque
le charlot 10 mme von à abdiquer en
faveur de son petit-fils finalement sera
obligé de quitter la france pour
s'exiler en angleterre pendant que les
choses d'un autre côté se met en place
et effectivement que chaques
louis-philippe premier monte sur le
trône au niveau de la france donc les
belgicains échoue à mettre en place un
régime républicain c'est-à-dire un
régime où c'est le peuple qui choisit
librement ses dirigeants ses dires et
ses dirigeants étant et même si excitant
sélectionné par lampard deux formations
politiques
j'aime que l'on connaît aujourd'hui six
jeux vidéo pour aller pour aller vite
les républicains chauds à mettre en
place un régime là puisque c'est la
monarchie constitutionnelle qui qui qui
l'emportent
une fois de plus mais les républicains
ont une très grande influence quand même
dans les affaires du royaume puisqu'il
siège à la chambre des députés
oui mais globalement on dira que les
c'est le mouvement je dirais
sur caractéristiques qui va représenter
un finalement le roi de france nous
émouvoir orléaniste qui va prédominer au
sein de l'assemblée et donc qui
détiendra la main une majorité relative
quand elle n'était pas absolue et au
niveau du nombre de députés et qui donc
va mettre en oeuvre la politique du
gouvernement et des gouvernements
successifs de cette monarchie de juillet
alors sous la monarchie de juillet qui
dure durant 18 ans on reviendra tout à
l'heure sur la manière dont elle s'est
délité il ya plusieurs initiatives
plusieurs décisions politiques qui
montre qu'un ce gouvernement-là composé
de modérer et de libéraux veut abolir
l'esclavagé dans les colonies mais ne
sait pas trop comment s'y prendre
finalement est-ce que j'exagère en
disant ça commence à penser que bon
c'est surtout que nombre d'individus il
écoute je dirais je vais pas dire qu'ils
écoutent la les informations qui
viennent des ports de l'atlantique
notamment mais ils sont sujets à des
courants d'opinion donc et beaucoup
d'entre eux ne sont pas des
abolitionniste convaincu certains
d'entre eux ne sont que les
abolitionnistes de circonstance des
circonstances donc ils voient la bouche
en esclavage a toujours de monoï donc
sachant surtout que ce qui se passe dans
les colonies anglaises avec
l'émancipation ou en 1834
à partir du 1er août 10 134 lorsqu'il
est mise en application
et si normalement pendant 4 à 6 ans
devait mettre en apprentissage les
esclaves des colonies anglaises et on
voit que ce n'est les résultats ne sont
pas aussi probant qu'on aurait voulu et
donc que les passants ont passé ben
parce qu'il fait à travailler des
individus pour leur ancien maître sur
les mêmes habitations alors qu'ils sont
censés être libre on est face à passe
mal du coach va s'entraîner fonctionne
pas très bien aussi bien pour les
esclaves domestiques que pour les
esclaves deschamps est donc finalement
en 1838 on a décidé d'abolir
définitivement l'esclavagé dans les
colonies anglaises on va finalement que
les quatre ans n'ont pas été pour
voiture justement de cette période de
temps nécessaire à mettre en avant
justement l'apprentissage de la liberté
et de la citoyenneté
naïve antigua qui est l'une de ces
colonies britanniques située au nord de
la guadeloupe le lavage et abolit
immédiatement le gouverneur qui ne veut
pas attendre cinq ans parce qu'il a peur
d'une déflagration
pour employer son santé en main au roi
d'angleterre à ce moment là donc ça
montre bien que l'expérience est
contrastée l'expérience des colonies
britanniques est contrastée ce qui met
dans l'embarras les abolitionnistes
français les plus immondes et oui ou non
les plus frileux disant oui donc ils ont
une preuve matérielle que cette
abolition de l'esclavagé
graduelle en quelque sorte même si elle
a été votée par le parlement britannique
et ne finalement ne fait pas ne fait pas
vraiment des heureux en tant au niveau
de la population ancien population
esclave es et les maîtres eux mêmes ne
sont pas convaincus de cette phase
d'apprentissage alors sous la monarchie
de juillet avec ses orléaniste libéraux
modérés se met en place tout de même une
commission parlementaire en mai 1840 qui
a pour but de voir comment justement on
peut s'inspirer des exemples britannique
pour voir dans les possessions colonie
française
les modalités de mise en oeuvre de
signes de cette émancipation et cette
commission travaille pendant presque
trois ans sur la direction des ducs
victoire de brouille elle remet son
rapport en 1843 et finalement ces
conclusions qui sont assez contrastés ne
semble même pas suivi d'effets non plus
non plus puisque effectivement un
historien anglophone lancée jennings a
dit que finalement soir la monarchie de
juillet se résume dans durant les seize
premières années de cette monarchie à
attendre et à finalement ne rien
précipiter
donc on ne cherche pas véritablement a
aboli l esclavage on propose il ya des
propositions d projet d'abolition sont
faits édifiants individus généralement
des propos des projets l'abolition
graduelle l'esclavagé mais après on
constate que on ne fait rien pour
faciliter cette abolition même graduelle
en cours et mettre d'en inscrire dans le
marbre de la loi c'est ses projets en
faire des soirées des ordonnances ou en
tout cas des lois qui serait applicable
immédiatement aux colonies aussi parce
que aux colonies les conseils coloniaux
900 contre est donc faux conseils
coloniale qui est qui et dans une
émanation des principaux propriétaires
d'habitations des différentes colonies
non c'est l'instance qui est déjà la
colonne ouvert qui gère la colonie
d'humains qui gère
en tout cas tout ce qui concerne les
affaires intérieures la goulette à faire
court après les affaires courantes et
notamment tout ce qui a trait à
condition d individus qui sont encore
esclaves et donc elle ne veut pas se à
ce niveau là qui est de chargement d'un
haut niveau de la conseille coloniaux
qui sont largement dominés par les
planteurs ou leurs représentants
oui par les planteurs et très peu très
peu de négociants sont intégrés à ces
conseils coloniaux même moment anthony
qui est malgré le poids de la place et
communes saint pierre à l'époque alors
une monarchie de juillet donc comme on
dit de 1830 à 1848 les modérés les
abolitionnistes mme déry finalement on
peu d'efficacité mais ce qui n'empêche
pas les abolitionnistes radicaux cette
vidéo des républicains de continuer de
militer pour une abolition
alors foncez antin immédiate et
universel pour les autres graduelle mais
quand même général donc il y a en fait
deux courants dans le même mouvement
abolitionniste y ont pu dire faites le
courant principal celui de la ffe reste
fine française pour l'abolition du
servage reste finalement assez modérée
donc ce qui aurait dû être fait par le
biais de ce mouvement abolitionniste les
pas véritablement et c'est vraiment dans
l'est la dernière année et demie de du
règne de louis-philippe conviera
justement la tendance immédiate east
comme on l'a appelé pour la wimedia de l
esclavage se mettre en branle et
notamment par le retour on a sur la
scène de vie de cyrille bissette qui est
à 10 145 va prendre contact avec
guillaume de félice un professeur à
l'université de montauban où ces
protestants dubois université de
montauban qui arrive à recontacter sur
le professeur pour au niveau du milieu
protestant rédiger une une
une programmation du moins une adresse
visant à l'abolition de l'esclavagé
attention notamment des chambres les
chambres la chambre des députés
notamment à l'otan que bissett fait
partie de ces abolitionniste natif des
colonies ils sont quelques uns parce que
nombreux à paris
17 on le rappelle les exilés les débats
ni enfin il a une condamnation il ne
peut pas on est en colonie puisqu'il a
été jugée en première instance puis en
appel il est donc il est obligé de
rester en france puisqu'elle ne peut pas
revenir dans son pays natal la
martinique il est en compagnie de ses
deux comparses ou présumés tels volny et
fabien louis fabien fils et donc
mais il y en ad'autres également
notamment certain victor mazu lim qui
est très peu connu c'est vrai mais qui
sont parmi ceux et celles qui milite
pour l'abolition de l'esclavagé mais
avec peut-être une vision différente de
celle des abolitionnistes français
parisienne parce que eux ils ont vécu de
près la condition des esclaves
soit qu'ils ont été eux mêmes pour
certains soit alors qu'ils ont dû au
quotidien comme bella la condition des
esclaves dans leurs colonies d'origine
oui à quelques individus qui ont tiré
qui ont les idées aux colonies
effectivement commun comme mazu lim qui
est un qui arrive de la forêt elle et
d'autres qui se sont engagés
effectivement aux côtés de cyrille
bissette notamment dei richard pour les
libres 2 couleurs de la guadeloupe avec
d'autres individus qui ont naturellement
fait partie aussi de la première loge
maçonnique des dix sites le dira mais en
guadeloupe qui au civa sera favorable à
l'abolition du servage dampierre aussi
bien aux colonies que qu'à paris
principalement les individus qui se sont
mobilisés autour de 17 po aider à mettre
en oeuvre cette abolition de l esclavage
mais c'est vrai que be set a été un
artisan principal
qui a milité grâce à sa revue des
colonies pour cette abolition immédiate
de l'esclavagé en dénonçant tous les
faits qui étaient qui avait lieu aux
colonies et qui étaient rapportés par
différents correspondants alors nous
arrivons enfin à la fin de ce régime de
la monarchie constitutionnelle de la
monarchie de juillet dans les premières
semaines de 1848 hélas déroule une
nouvelle révolution apparemment la
révolution est l'apanage du peuple
français du peuple parisien en tout cas
oui bon c'est pas si l'apanage du feu
parisienne l'enterrer effectivement on
contacte dans l'histoire de france
en l'espace de 50 ans beaucoup de choses
se sont passées
effectivement à paris capitale
administrative de la france
effectivement dans 22 23 24 février 1848
à nouveau parce que le monarque louis
philippe et son principal ministre
françois guizot qui ne voulait rien
changé notamment au régime électoral en
élargissant le corps électoral pour
représenter correctement je dirais les
différents courants au sein de
de la vie politique et publique ne
voulait rien changé toujours gardé cette
cette monarchie sans hésiter à qui
mettait en avant des individus les plus
fortunés qui par le biais d'une
représentation 200 francs de sens pour
être éligible ses enfants de sens pour
être élu donc on ne veut rien changé
donc alors que bon on estime que le
corps législatif ce nom devrait être un
peu plus large plage de la cité
à l'image de la société pour mieux
représenter justement cette dernière au
sein des assemblées bon et comme il ne
veut rien changer
donc un système d'une volonté de banquet
est mise en place par les républicains
qui est repoussé par le prophète police
et ceci en février le 22 février décide
pour autant de passer outre et de se
réunir et donc on verra une partie de la
population parisienne notamment des
étudiants et des ouvriers se se
positionner et dit non c'est justement
cette politique gouvernementale et très
vite en fait non seulement la garde
nationale parisienne celle qui est
censée soutenir le régime monarchiste ne
va pas sortir à l'appel de du ministre
de l'intérieur mais il va rester dans
les casernes
montrons par ce biais qu'elle se
désolidarise de du tournant conservateur
de la monarchie de juillet est donc ce
qu'il fallait va faciliter grandement
l'évolution très rapide des choses
puisque guizhou après this
précipitations fera ses valises et sous
les huées du peuple parisien devant le
ministère de l'intérieur est donc
finalement oui philippe n'aura pas
d'autre choix que de dons que de quitter
de quitter de quitter lui aussi la place
et comme son cousin avant lui donc et
cette mise en place la république
française sera proclamé demain la
deuxième république sera proclamé le 25
février 1848 et des individus seront
mises en avant très vite par le biais
des organes de deux journaux le mot
dirait l'autre
un peu plus engagés dans le mouvement
socialiste qui vont nommer les individus
que l'on connaît du gouvernement
provisoire
arago garnier pagès ledru rollin et
lamartine notamment avec d'autres nous
sommes en face à la première
notre émission si on remonte inique la
première avec aujourd'hui un bel louis
historien et nous parlons donc de ce
cent soixante dixième anniversaire de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé du 27 avril
1848 et donc un bel lui qui vient de
nous dire que le gouvernement provisoire
issu de la révolution de février se met
en place et prend en attendant une
décision politique forte parmi lesquels
l'abolition de la peine de mort le
rétablissement de la liberté de la
presse d'opinion de réunion et
d'expression
le suffrage universel certes réservé aux
hommes les femmes d'euros tant en france
qu'en un siècle plus tard en 1944
et puis l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans
les colonies ses possessions est ce
qu'il y a une manière de hiérarchie
entre ces différentes mesures ou est-ce
que vous l'aimez triés sur le même plan
il ya des mesures qui sont quand même
très importante pour au niveau national
c'est vrai que le rétablissement du
suffrage universel
il est important puisqu'il va permettre
à une population qui jusqu'àlors n'ai
jamais voté de prendre part au débat
politique et donc c'est très intéressant
à ce niveau là la peine de mort à ses
partisans et ses opposants que je
préfère ce titre chaque camp se ferait
un point de vue là-dessus et
naturellement aux pour concernant les
colonies
le fait de deux prix voir une abolition
le possible de reconnaître la pré sident
de l'abolition de l'esclavagé de mettre
en oeuvre une commission qui va
favoriser cette abolition de l'esclavagé
est aboli ces immédiate de l esclavage
donc sera très important pour les
colonies mais naturellement le régime de
reconnaître aussi le cette liberté de la
presse aura aussi son importance
puisqu'elle sera aussi appliquée aux
colonies et donc ça permettra
effectivement d'avoir une presse
d'opinion qui va se partager et
s'opposer en martinique notamment entre
les partisans de la république non
plutôt coûter cher
plutôt que le côté shell chérissent tu
es donc et ceux qui voudront bouderont
metheny au conservé par dix ans de
l'union entre les entre les classes
entre les noirs et blancs qui seront
plutôt favorable à bis était donc voilà
donc c'est sûr que le il était d'après
sera aussi sera aussi intéressant ça
nous redonne ainsi alors une d'une
petite semaine après la restauration du
gouvernement brisant le 24 février le 4
mars
victor schoelcher est nommé sous
secrétaire d'état aux colonies par son
ministre de tutelle françois arago qui
avait publiquement un savon
un astronome réputé à l'époque c'est un
monsieur qui est déjà âge il ya
quasiment 70 ans mais qui est une
autorité une figure morale et ce qu'il
en est ce qui peut paraître anecdotique
c'est que celle cher revient la veille
le 3 mars des singles i sénégal
possessions françaises où l'esclavagé
était en vigueur et il revient d'une
campagne pour l'abolition du servage et
débarquant au havre il se précipite à
paris ils arrivent au siège du
gouvernement provisoire ou là il se fait
nommer si je puis dire ce sacre est de
taille fait pression mais bon une région
qu'ils n'ont pas très longtemps puisque
le suspense radio que quelques heures
puisqu'il sera membre de ce gouvernement
oui demain il sera membre du
gouvernement ministre par l'un des 11
mai reste activement en étroite
collaboration avec le ministre de la
marine et des colonies est effectivement
ben c'est l'homme le plus en vue donc
c'était logique car à gauche que les
autres pensent à lui éventuellement
puisque c'est lui qu'on avait le plus vu
par ses écrits depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années
donc voilà donc il était logique que
qu'on fasse appel à lui comme le plus
qualifié puisqu'il s'était entendu aux
colonies dans les antilles aussi bien
française qu'anglophones et hispanophone
donc il avait vu de près ce c'est un
genre d'expérience aux experts de se
positionner cela va donc il a puisqu'il
a vu la vie des esclaves sur les
plantations même si effectivement
cyrille bissette soulignera qu'il aura
été reçus principalement par des grands
propriétaires d'habitations et donc il
n'aura qu'une vision partielle partiel
parfois d'ascq de certains éléments mais
en tout cas il est le principal
connaisseur de de ce qu'il faudrait pour
mettre en faudrait mettre en place dans
l'application de cette abolition
esclavage mais on ne bat alors c'est
facile aujourd'hui de faire de la
politique fiction mais pourquoi le
gouvernement provisoire n'a pas noué par
exemple quelqu'un comme bissett y avait
beaucoup et max martin n'avait pas le
même entre aux gens ils n'avaient pas la
même influence
il ya sans doute le fait que en tant que
membre de ce gîte aux enchères
appartenait à je dirais des grands
ensembles
non seulement il appartenait à la
société française pour la wii en
esclavage mais il appartenait aussi là
était franc-maçon donc il ya d une
conjonction de faits et de qui permette
qui favorise justement que ce soit a
chuté au chai hin et pas un autre
et donc tu aimais introduit par tous les
abonnés c'est à ce moment là voilà alors
ils cherchent à met en place le 4 mars
il est d'ailleurs un décret est publié
je peux vous lire le texte de ce décret
c'est très courant c'est un article
unique d'ailleurs je retrouve mes notes
le gouvernement provisoire de la
république considérant que nous luttions
française ne peut plus porter d'esclaves
décrète une commission est institué
auprès du ministre provisoire de la
marine et des colonies ont préparé dans
le plus bref délais l'acte
d'émancipation immédiate dans toutes les
colonies de la république
enfin salué le défunt du 4 mars donc qui
met en place les conditions pour arriver
à l'émancipation par l'intermédiaire
d'une commission qui travaille dès le 6
mars
cette commission comme vous le disiez
composé de sept personnes et dans
parmi ces sept personnes il y adeux
martin guindon le assez connu perrine
ans qui aurait pu être un faux mais
également je pense et abyss est
maintenant que j'y pense et atterrit non
françois henri pinault premier
martiniquais ont reçu à l'école
polytechnique donc il est officier de
l'artillerie qui le lie en congé de
l'armée à ce moment là il a acheté des
terres des salines une exploitation de
salim différent du sel de mer de saint
martin où il veut démontrer que le
travail salarié et plus rentable que le
travail est servile et donc il a comme
employé aussi bien des esclaves que des
salariés et il arrive à la démontrer par
j'allais dire la pratique et perrine on
a quand même une influence aussi dans le
milliard boli sioniste parisien et il
fait partie de cette commission
socialiste d'experts qui travaille sous
la supervision de chercheurs pour voir
comment on peut mettre en place les
modalités d'accession des esclaves à la
liberté oui mon père françois auguste au
piano il a jeté un passé colonial
important puisque sa mère rose fillon
était une marchande importante et une
propriété en main pour autant à saint
pierre sous la monarchie de juillet dont
il a bénéficié je dirais il à être tiré
bénéfice par sa mère du système
esclavagiste et d'où peut-être son côté
modéré puisqu'il a même grandi dans ce
système esclavagiste qui là qu'il a vu
de près même si les parties fait qu'ils
ont à 16 17 ans pour la france pour
poursuivre ses études
mais c'est quelqu'un qui vient d'un
milieu aisé au niveau colonies coloniale
donc qu'ils n'avaient peut-être pas
comme d'autres une vision je dirais plus
plus radicale de ce qu'il fallait ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour pour abolir
l'esclavagé et facilité en tout cas
famille dans sa mise en oeuvre
mais effectivement il a vu qu'il a au
contact sans doute de ses études en
france et en fréquentant peut-être
effectivement lui aussi en tant que
franc maçon à metz notamment ces groupes
de réflexion il a il a pu mettre en
pratique des idées qu'il a développée
lui-même effectivement par la suite dans
les salines de saint valentin est donc
et faire oeuvre à son niveau de manière
beaucoup plus modérée que celle cher
beaucoup moins engagé donc son avis sur
le travail libre aux colonies qui est
quittée selon li possible alors donc
autres prix dont il yad'autres d'autres
personnalités
nous allons y revenir une autre fois il
ya plusieurs auditions de représentants
des planteurs comme notre vision tout à
l'heure d'abolitionnistes bas rizières
ou un type des colonies finalement la
commission sans son avis et qui sera
celle des 10 et cristallisé dans ce
fameux décret du 27 avril qui comprend
neuf à l'antique et qui organise les
modalités de mise en oeuvre de
l'abolition mais avec la difficulté
c'est que une première difficulté
pardon c'est que ce l'abolition devait
être effective dans chacune des colonies
dans un délai de deux mois à compter de
la date à laquelle le décret à vivre est
aux mains du nouveau gouverneur nommé
pour bien mener à une autre difficulté
c'est que on le savait que l' esclavage
on ne savait dans les colonies que l'
esclavage il était prévu que l'esclavagé
fut abolie dans un temps indéterminé
donc c'était dans les rangs si je puis
dire donc oui effectivement le on savait
que donc à partir du moment où le les
décrets ont été signés par le
gouvernement provisoire 27 avril mai
mais depuis début mars ans avait
effectivement aux colonies que
l'abolition est dans l'air et donc on
attend impatiemment qu'elle a arrivé il
ya deux rives paraît naïf a donc
effectivement un mois deux mois passent
donc en fin avril
il ya des attitudes des habitations qui
se produisent en martinique notamment et
qui ont été mises en évidence notamment
par edouard delépine dont dans son
ouvrage sur dix semaines qui ébranlèrent
la martinique et on constate
effectivement que les esclaves commence
à s'agiter parce qu'ils ne voient rien
venir
alors qu'ils savent que c'est prévu
alors qu'en réalité on sait qu'il ya eu
la révolution fait oublier on le sait en
gros en mi mars
trois semaines à peu près on connaît
l'existence d'état le décret du 4 mars
au mois d'avril euros mois en prêt mais
mes début avril la mi avril
donc on sait qu'il ya des choses qui se
prépare sans ça m'a surtout qu'il ya une
une qui est pas une
une erreur faite par le nouveau
directeur de l'intérieur husson qui dans
un texte en créole dit a dit que
l'abolition devenir notre doc ça c'était
pour calmer les choses
oui mais pour les esclaves ça n'a pas
calmé les choses autrement et c'est bien
sûr à venir on attend un patient mais en
tout cas effectivement les commissaires
généraux de la république qui était
censé apporter les décrets vont arriver
en martinique en tout cas lui dis-je une
dizaine de jours après le mouvement de
l'insurrection et l'insurrection des
esclaves du prêcheur et de saint-pierre
donc il va constater de visu que
l'abolition a déjà été proclamé le 23
par le gouverneur rostollan et donc
alors qu'il n'était pas d'accord pour
pour qu'on change les décrets pour
indiquer que l abolition est immédiate
et qui aura pas ce délai de deux mois
n'en qu'il il est convaincu par
différents individus lille recevra au
resto non lui-même le gouvernement en
place à l'époque et aussi par quelques
hommes de couleur qui était favorable à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
ben oui oui oui papilles et à saint
pierre où alfred agnès pour pour
justement ne rien changer à cette
abolition de 23 ans précisant que ce
gouverneur c'est perrine en face à
ospina
on avait en tant que général le
commissaire général dane qui arrive
effectivement avec les décret du 27
avril et 13 décret et autres
instructions arrêté qui accompagne ce
décret mais il arrive le 3 à saint
pierre le 3 juin contre 1 3 juin est bon
il ne s'est pas un sais pas ce qui s'est
passé dix jours auparavant les
défendeurs mais et c'est là qu'on voit
que effectivement que queen on est quand
même très modérée il lui le il pensait
bêtement appliquer maintenant appliquer
les directives
énoncée par le gouvernement provisoire
l'histoire leur a devancé et donc nous
aurons l'occasion de revoir dans une
autre émission si vous vous levez bien
madame monsieur et monsieur abel oui que
je remercie infiniment de d'être venu
nous éclairer de ces lumière sur les
circonstances dans lesquelles le décret
du 27 avril a été signé puisque il ya
des choses qui se sont passées entre le
4 mars et le 23 mai nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir largement sur nos
antennes
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui pour
notre émission face à la première avec
ab louis historienne spécialiste de la
période du 19e siècle en martinique et
qui a beaucoup travaillé sur les libres
de couleur veiller notamment leur
importance dans la vie économique et
politique
à saint-pierre et enfants de france
cette émission a été réalisée
aujourd'hui parents paul eric toussaint
à bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]